julianne hough is revealing her get fit
secrets hey guys I'm Sara Flanagan and
we're taking you behind the scenes of
our shape magazine cover shoot I like to
workout probably five times a week I'll
wake up and that's probably the first
thing that I'll do and then at night I
really like to kind of decompress and
stretch and do things before I go to bed
when she's not sweating and stretching
she's eating healthy protein and veggies
I stick to that but I definitely add in
rice or some quinoa every now and then
to give me some more energy between
being a full time judge on Dancing with
the Stars and in romance with NHL star
Brooks like Julianne keeps a pretty busy
schedule but she finds ways to make
Fitness a priority even when she's on
the go I carry my little like wrist and
ankle weights with me I have like a
little elastic band I bring my vitamins
and I sometimes bring my protein shake
mix Julianne wasn't always this
dedicated I used to be on a strict diet
and work out really hard and then I kind
of get burnout or I'd get really tired
and so then I would just go on the like
no working out and I'm gonna eat
whatever I want for a couple weeks and
then I'd go back it just wasn't very
balanced check out more of Julian's
interview with shape magazine when it
hit stands tomorrow